we are gonna do this on a new set of
axes because it's going to get too busy
otherwise however I'm going to make an
argument about this and I'm going to
appeal to the previous diagram that we
just drew okay so you don't need to draw
this I actually don't want you to draw
on your original one because it's just
going to get too clouded but I want you
to look at mine my original graph of
sine X and sine squared on it as I make
this argument again let's think about
ordinates okay remember that is what
were those easy ornaments that you
picked out for me before in this graph 1
negative 1 and 0 there are all really
easy ordinance to work with ok so if
they've any bang-bang-bang
great I've got some printers but then I
said ok well tell me about the behavior
about the other spots that I'm not as
easy to identify so I picked out a spot
laxatives
okay let's suppose that would admit it
was a huff okay so when you square it
what happens you get 1/4 right so my
scales not the greatest but it's close
enough now that makes sense I'm half the
distance if I cube instead of square I'm
not going to go to 1/4 am i I'm gonna go
for a half to 1/8 right I'm going to be
squashed in underneath there right I'm
always in fact because I'm always
between zero one prisoner and I said are
9/10 ok that's gonna be up here 9/10 is
0.9 when I Square I'm gonna get 81 over
100 which is 0.8 1 some low up and they
were my cube what's like you
it's 729 over a thousand that's the zero
point 7 to 9
do you see the pattern right because I
stay between 0 1 because I'm dealing
with fractions this whole time every
single one of these X's that I draw it's
always going to be underneath every
single time right so if I could describe
this even
well the stationery was it one right so
it's still gonna keep it one it's the
one so I'm still gonna get up to that
point but I'm gonna get up there in a
steep of way like this everything is
more extreme okay so now when I come
here right the first part that I draw
from north 180 is now very very similar
to what I just drew there in blue it's
just going to be more extreme like so
okay that's more or less the same except
it's like this it's more point okay but
then something quite different happens
when I cross over while I'm training
degrees and go from 180 to 360 what's
different okay it's gonna go underneath
right cuz we're squaring I've got even
powers so you're gonna get even numbers
of negative signs but you don't get even
numbers of negative signs here right if
sine X is negative the Q sine X will
also be negative okay
so you're gonna come down here like so
there you go right so what I conclude
out of this just like I said even powers
eliminate side odd powers because if you
did this is about five of power seven of
course you can get the same kind of
Panama odd powers start a limit sign a
preserve sign and in conclusion based on
this element I made hue in the black
craft and all the exes of these values
to you right now higher you make your
power the more extreme you make the
behavior okay I suppose if I will do
like sine X to the power of like a
hundred or something like that what
you're going to expect is something like
this like that okay so definitely I was
marking some you ten tests today and I
was pretty stickers on some because they
got like their full marks and which I
don't have my stickers with me but I
will defer that and if you were okay
does that make sense you sure we're
doing right so number one we've noticed
that even this anonymous right and what
that does decide and we've also notice
what happens as you increase the power
as you get higher up you get more
extreme behavior okay in fact I might
even write that because it's such an
important idea high powers results in
more extreme behavior you'll lose get
lower and even though I don't have any
of them on this particular graph suppose
our graph went outside one a negative
one right like suppose actually let's
just quickly do this now informally we
just did sine X right let's do
I staged suicide X that's all we need
yeah
okay now really quickly we don't need to
argue this too much if I consider this
green graph as y equals two sine X
that's why my amplitude is negative two
to two okay now if I compare this like
just doing the square right when you
square this you get four sine squared X
so you can see hey look look my
institute of course is higher right if
I'm doing the squared one everything's
gonna stay positive like that guy over
there so now the crests of this graph
are gonna be well they give you twice as
high right so they'll be up here for
like so and I guess that would be not to
have one up here right so you're gonna
hear this kind of behavior yes you would
exactly that point there it's like well
wherever I did it quickly right so so
you'd expect actually there should have
really intercept around there okay
there's that more extreme behavior that
I should expect that's why it should
come up faster and dropped off all so
far